hey folks so in this video you're gonna
see me react to some of the supposedly
great Ben Shapiro Mullins the Ben
Shapiro destroys moments so it begins
being Braves being yourself and being
transgender is it's about the bravest
thing you can do does she deserve the or
five yes why are we mainstreaming
delusion it's not the Lou why would you
call it delusion because Bruce Caitlyn
Jenner I'll call him Caitlyn Jenner
that's you're not being polite to the
pronoun because it's respect okay forget
about the disrespect facts don't care
about your feelings it turns out that
every chromosome every cell in Caitlyn
Jenner's body is male with the exception
of some of his sperm cells you it turns
out they were tiny it turns out that he
still has all of his male appendages how
he feels on the inside is irrelevant to
the question of his biological so agree
with that I'm not on that he wants to be
called Shi so you don't know what you're
talking about you're not educated on
genetics or genetics so I'd stay away
from the genetics and back to the brain
scans you cut that out now or you'll go
home in an ambulance yeah that seems
mildly inappropriate for a political
discussion yeah this one is wild there's
a lot to this particular backstory so
first of all I was invited on the
program and backstage the producer says
you know I used to produce Jerry
Springer this should've been my first
hint that things were gonna get wild and
I said you know you know my perspective
on this and the person's bright that's
why we're having you on we want it to be
like a lively debate we want you just
express your opinions and and everything
all right fine so then the way they seat
this obviously is they see Zoe turn
right next to me and pretty quickly this
thing goes off the rails because the
moment that anybody suggests that
perhaps a genetic male is actually a
genetic male and that a genetic male
believes he as a female is just a
delusional male that this that
apparently is is unstable now again that
sounds to suggest that the gender
dysphoria isn't tragic it is tragic but
to suggest that a person with gender
dysphoria is therefore a member of the
sex to which they claim membership is of
course absurd on its face so as you can
see this debate started to go off the
rails even before Zoe turn decided to
get physical in the debate you can see
people saying I'm being disrespectful to
pronouns which is bizarre cuz pronouns
aside from facts not having feel
actually pronouns don't have feelings
either as it turns out and then the
entire movement of the debate away from
the realm of the rational toward we're
just going to insult people and Zoe turd
suggested you don't know anything about
genetics little boy you don't know
anything about genetics and when I asked
him about his genetics that's when the
the physical threat came out what was
funny is right after this when the rest
of the panel immediately swiveled and
turned on me you knew you were going to
offend Zoe that way you knew you were
going to offend so ok well number one I
generally prefer an honest
honest-to-goodness I promise you this I
was not thinking in the moment I'm going
to call this person Sir in order to
insult them this is a large physical
male sitting next to me who's speaking
directly to me and that's just that's
how I speak to men I mean this is a man
and the and so it sort of came out
unconsciously and then the fact that Zoe
Turk got physical about and start making
physically violent threats on the set
that was something I didn't expect to
happen
my main reaction there was just
puzzlement I honestly could not believe
that this was a thing that was happening
on national television it was absolute
bizarro world but after this happened
and Zoe eater on the way out kind of
growls at me I'll see you in the parking
lot a little boy and I was like wow that
is a weird take as my mother later says
my mother later said not not very
ladylike behavior and I said well no I'm
not gonna meet you in the parking lot
that's that's a thing that's not going
to happen and then later of course Zoe
turn threatened to curb stop me on
Twitter also not super ladylike behavior
and the debate turned into you're not
allowed to use somebody's pronouns when
you are somebody's proper genetic
pronouns when you are talking to them on
national TV now as I've said before if I
am in a conversation with somebody at
dinner and there are a friend it's not a
public debate I'll call you whatever you
want to call I really don't care but
when it comes to having a public debate
about whether a male is in fact a male
or a female is in fact female I'm not
going to cede the ground of the argument
by going along with the lie that a
genetic male is in fact a female so that
that's sort of the that's sort of the
back story there whatever what a bizarre
moment in time that was my
[Applause]
[Music]
your baby
[Applause]
this pretty famous because obviously I'm
flipping off the protesters I wasn't
just flipping them off randomly what
happened is that the the person who I
was flipping off started flipping off
the entire crowd as well as me and so
that is a defensive flip off Han did not
fire first in this particular case so
there they were flipping me off and I
flipped them back up the whole thing was
ridiculous
you had a bunch of protesters they lined
up in front of the stage they held the
thing up for about 15 minutes we were
told that they couldn't be cleared from
the room because if the police cleared
them from the room then they would have
to clear everyone from the room for some
odd reason which of course is silliness
these folks also didn't seem to
understand that I had chalk and a
moveable chalkboard behind me so that
allowed me to do the little visual sight
gag there by writing morons on the board
and putting it right above them as sort
of a placard but it does demonstrate the
level of debate that's being had on some
of these college campuses I'm not sure
what shouting safety has to do with
anything the last time someone shot at
safety of me were in seventh grade and
someone had farted but these kids
apparently decided that it was a great
idea to shout safety as though there was
some sort of threat to them with a bunch
of police officers in the room and with
everybody treating them quite civilly I
remember actually walked up to the front
of stage I said to somebody do you want
have a discussion on this stuff like you
want to at some point you want actually
like talk about this and person kind of
realized I was talking them and shook
their head said no and we waited for
them to leave and then finally they took
off but again this is this is not high
level debate and it just demonstrates a
counterproductive some of these protests
are because they got much more attention
for the speech by being idiots than they
ever would have if they just ignored it
no no this wasn't a scary one and there
are there are a few of these college
speeches that are in scary this was
definitely not a scary one these I mean
my security was off to the side of the
room there were several cops there and
frankly this did not look like a
particularly threatening group of human
beings so I hey I may not be a jujitsu
warrior but I felt confident in my
capacity to maintain my own physical
safety with this particular crowd and
this is how it's written you will and
there it is gang
[Music]
guess what you know what they're not
going to stop us
[Applause]
alright maligne abdullah fan Ruben
Martin wrote you want I should avoid
them boss
I got a fuse ideas me and the fellas
been kicking around only thing is he
won't be talking or looking so nice no
more we'll take the cannolis
the reason I'm reading it in this way is
because this is exactly how it's written
Loida misspelled h o IW t apostrophe am
speaking of professor abdullah she
posted this on her facebook wall earlier
this week folks if you're just joining
the livestream somebody pulled the fire
alarm to stop this cuz this is how the
fascists do it so this one was was
actually the wildest college experience
and this is one of the first ones that
sort of led off the entire college tour
it really got off the university of
missouri but this was shortly thereafter
University of Missouri was 2015 this was
what February 2016 I believe and the the
students outside who had decided to
essentially riot I mean they're they're
outside they were threatening people
they were pushing people around in the
crowd we were told by the police they
couldn't guarantee our safety if we left
the room I had to be escorted in by by a
set of police officers I had to be
escorted out backdoor by a set of police
officers it was it was quite amazing
that all of that was because there were
professors at the University who were
seriously suggesting that I was a white
supremacist like a KKK member which is
which is pretty incredible the students
had to be smuggled in two at a time it
was the whole thing was just a complete
bleep show from beginning to end on the
part of the university it ended with the
lawsuit actually but this is one of the
few times where I think I wasn't
physically afraid because I had so many
police officers around me and I had
security but I was afraid for the other
students because at one point I said to
the students you guys want to go out
there and we'll have a talk with some of
the people outside and the police were
like no you don't no no no that that is
a bad idea and so they said you know we
can protect you we can't protect the
other students said okay dude we'll just
wait and said we literally waited inside
until the crowd dissipated it was pretty
incredible somebody obviously pulled the
fire alarm in there because they wanted
to shut down the speech the speech by
the way it was all about how diversity
of thought was important but diversity
of race wasn't particularly important
which I thought was relatively
uncontroversial because I'm not sure why
skin color should be the be-all end-all
or even a significant factor in life
but that was you know too much for the
for the kids at CSULA said to handle
apparently what I can't think that
Donald Trump colluded glad more potent
yes I do not because I watched that
campaign I don't think that Donald Trump
could collude with his own left foot
well I don't think he did it but his you
know his son did it his is the people
who are Muller is and when the evidence
comes out I'm happy to go for the
indictments I'm fine criminal activities
criminal acts but you see she didn't do
but wearing his to ignorance who have
done it well he's not to ignorance in a
criminal this whole life the Trump
defender here but is he a doofus or is
he an evil genius you got to pick one
okay actually you don't you don't have
to pick one really look I'm not saying
he's like Hitler hurry but it was crazy
and he was a genius at what he did which
was lie and manipulate people so you can
be both what was funny about that the
Bill Maher interview is that first of
all I enjoy Bill Maher I think that Bill
Maher will say shockingly true things
from time to time I mean he's definitely
down the line lefty on a lot of policy
but not when it comes to things like
free speech and the willingness to talk
with the other side like that stuff that
Bill Maher is correct about he has put
less politically correct than then a lot
of his colleagues what was weird about
this particular episode of Bill Maher is
a few things one the timing was weird so
I can only do Bill Maher like once a
year because they do it live on Friday
nights and that means that I can only do
it when Friday night like Shabbat comes
in very late so we can basically do it
one time a year so this one time that
year I could only stay for like the
first 15 minutes and then I had to run
and we actually negotiated with them
that I would do that but not be on the
panel I'd have to take off as soon as I
did the the lead interview my assumption
was and all the pre interviews were
about free speech college campuses
ability to talk to one another and all
of the rest about five minutes before
the show happens his producer comes in
and says you know bill really wants to
talk about Trump in Russia and I was
like really what wait why this is
remember this was in
middle of the Moller investigation but
nothing had really come out at that
point that was supremely damning I said
we can talk about that but I'm not sure
there's gonna be that much there it
turned into like a 15 minute
conversation about Trump and Russia and
so it kind of went in a different
direction than I thought it was going to
go but it is it was demonstrative of one
thing which is that when it comes to
President Trump there are a lot of
people who read the headline and they
don't read the body of the story and so
they get from the headline Trump Russia
collusion evil manipulative election
stealing and then they don't read the
story where it turns out that the
headline is a is a vast oversell and
that was really the story of Trump
Russia collusion it was a vast oversell
by the media it was a vast oversell by
the Democrats and and that bled down to
people like Bill I think I think even
the audience started to recognize you
can hear it in some of the clips that
the logic just doesn't hold together
that at a certain point you have to
acknowledge that Donald Trump is either
a boob or he's a genius and it can't be
all of these things and so when when you
actually say to an audience of people
who disagree listen we have the same
moral standard here you break the law
you go to jail but I just don't think
the evidence is there it makes it very
difficult for people to argue with that
point I mean we agreed on the
fundamentals right you can even see this
we're agreeing on the fundamentals which
is if you break the law you go to jail
if somebody colluded to to steal the
election you go to jail and you
shouldn't be President but I was just
saying all you need is the evidence here
and no evidence was actually presented
honestly piers you've kind of been a
bully on this issue because what you do
and I've seen it repeatedly on your show
I watch your show and I've seen it
repeatedly what you tend to do is you
tend to demonize people who differ from
you politically by standing on the
graves of the children of Sandy Hook
saying they don't seem to care enough
about the dead kids if they cared more
about the dead kids they would agree
with you on policy I think we can have a
rational political conversation about
balancing rights and risks and rewards
of all of these different policies but I
don't think that what we need to do is
demonize people on the other side as as
being unfeeling about that about what
happened in Santa you accuse me of
standing on the graves I've seen you do
it repeatedly piers like I say how dare
you I mean you can keep saying that but
you've done it repeatedly what you do
and I've seen you do it on the program
is you keep saying to folks that if they
disagree with you politically then
somehow this is a violation of what
happened in Sandy Hook and you have yet
I really like to hear your policy
rip shins for what we should do about
guns because you say that you respect
the Second Amendment and you know I
brought this here for you so that you
can read it it's a constitution and I
would really like for you to explain to
me what you would do about guns that
would have prevented what happened in
Sandy Hook ok so this was this was maybe
my first big TV appearance I'd done some
TV before this I'd been on Dennis Miller
show on CNBC before that I had done Joe
Scarborough show back when was called
Scarborough Country on MSNBC that that
was back in 2004 but this was the first
one where people really started to take
note of oh this guy is actually fairly
good at debating there were a couple
things that I'd planned so I had planned
right from the outset that I was going
to tell him exactly why I thought he was
a bully and that's because he had
written a column specifically on this
topic and because his producers had
basically said he's gonna bring this up
so I knew I was gonna say that I also
knew that at some point I was gonna hand
him the Constitution because he clearly
didn't care about it and really didn't
know much about it and so that that was
pre-planned I mean otherwise I don't
routinely just carry around the pocket
Constitution I have most of it up here
so the interview starts and peers opens
and he this is not going the way that he
thought it was going to go but two
nights before it hit head-on Alex Jones
and that made bit like a big splash for
him because Alex Jones is nuts and so
Alex Jones had threatened him like if
you dig my gardens I'm gonna come after
you would there's good I'm gonna shoot
you right that that kind of thing and
that's exactly what Piers Morgan wanted
because he wanted to portray gun to
ownership advocates as crazy people who
are ready and raring to go when it comes
to shooting people he has me on I start
off I'm being pretty reasonable I think
he got very offended obviously by the
fact that I suggested that he was
standing on the graves of the kids at
Sandy Hook to push a political agenda
but that's pretty much what he was doing
that was his tactic at the time and he
had actually there's a little
behind-the-scenes they went to break a
little bit early because he didn't
really like how it was going and he
brought in a they wheeled in somebody in
a wheelchair who'd actually been a
victim of a shooting and he I could see
they were getting ready to swivel the
camera so that he could say you know
look at this pool a child who was shot
it and then you know are you gonna say
to this person that you still think the
guns ought to be illegal and I had
already foreclosed that by saying that
he was actively utilizing people who
were hurt in shootings or killed in
shootings as
for political agenda as opposed to
having a rational discussion about risks
and rewards and benefits and
particularly gun policies it took it
took it away from them the part of this
interview that people always forget is
the part where he brought the sudafed
boxes and tried to suggest that it was
harder to buy sudafed than it was to buy
a gun which of course is not remotely
true if you buy a gun from a federally
licensed firearms dealer there's in many
cases a waiting period you have to go
through a background check but but in
any case the as the interview finishes I
said to him you know thanks mr. Morgan
knows those really great I really
appreciate it any kind of scenario that
maybe wasn't it wasn't super happy well
one of the funniest things about this
interview is of course the the afterlife
of the interview so this made you know
big waves
it sort of blunted the impact of he had
been gaining some ratings momentum it
wasn't great for a show on CNN but the
part that was that was you know pretty
amazing is that fast-forward a few years
and piers has been moved to moved on
from from CNN and now we're pretty
friendly like Pierce appeared Lorne is
actually a really great guy like I
actually like Piers a lot I think he's
an interesting guy I think that he has
learned some things about the
Constitution or at least how much we
value the Constitution here in the
United States certainly he wasn't in the
Sunday special I did with him he wasn't
taking the little book and throwing it
at me anymore I said that that was
definitely an upside just goes to show
you that you know a lot of the political
debate you see on TV is TV and some of
it is real
but if you can see each other as human
beings the likelihood is that more of
our conversations would look more like
my Sunday special and fewer of them
would look like the sort of pyrotechnics
you saw in this particular episode
all right folks well thanks for watching
if you want to see me react to more of
my own greatest moments all you have to
do is leave some comments down below
tell me which videos you'd like to see
me comment on and we'll see you here
next time
you